[Music]
you
[Music]
beef can access is an innovative
ultrasound device specifically designed
for primary healthcare settings in a low
resource environment to screen
complications in pregnancy in 2010 GE
Healthcare made a commitment to United
Nations to design deliver a solution
that will really help challenges around
the maternal and child health and in
2012 we were approached by GE Healthcare
to start exploring the needs of Viscount
access and the first thing that that
involved was actually going out to the
field and understanding the users who
are actually engaging and using this
product in the future to try and
understand how they would actually use
it what their needs were and the kind of
environment that they worked in what was
really important in developing the user
experience of the bees can access a
noble design development was to combine
the accuracy of a medical device they
trust ribbon a service
we were very accessible and seamless
user experience tailor to first-time
users hence the interface had to be very
clear in guiding them through the
clinical process as well as giving them
a sure and step-by-step that they're
using the device in the right way that
they taking measurements in the accurate
way
so since the launch of our product last
year we've installed more than thousand
sites across the globe and we've also
worked with them closely to make sure
that the these products are being used
to me the relationship between the
designer and the client is what lays the
foundation to how far you can go with a
product and a design as designers at
chemistry to fundamentally apply a human
centered design approach so any project
that we start every time we always start
with the user the users at the core of
this also applied of course to the
design of the Riskin access so here
fundamentally was important to start if
the user understand the needs and
challenges and develop the design
solutions based on that this design
approach doesn't stop with the version
that we have on the market
we'll continue to get feedback listen
and iterate on this process on our next
revision as well
[Music]
[Music]